[Applaudissements]
m
dans la préface à la phénoménologie de
l'esprit eagle écrit à la satisfaction
d'un esprit on mesure l'étendue de ses
pertes
je voudrais commencer par réfléchir à
partir de cette phrase le premier truc à
relever c'est le mot est tendue ça nous
situe sur un mode quantitatif
c'est un petit peu comme si le monde de
l'esprit comme le monde physique était
représentée sur une carte
voilà le territoire possible à explorer
avec ses différentes régions suivant son
ambition philosophique eagle parcours le
domaine de l'esthétique de la science de
la métaphysique et c'est monsieur dupont
quant à lui à un autre rapport à la
connaissance en dilettante il se cultive
lien petit les offices de temps en temps
regarde des vidéos youtube de
vulgarisation scientifique va au cinéma
voir la dernière palme d'or mais il ne
creuse pas plus que ça ce n'est pas un
chercheur en philosophie ou en sciences
n'est pas non plus un cinéphile
insatiable qui avale un crocodile aux
reflets entre deux films passant rue
champollion
il se contente de cette relation plutôt
légère avec les territoires potentiel de
l'esprit parce que oui en effet on peut
imaginer que chaque domaine est comme un
territoire un peu comme visiter une
ville et se confrontent en guise
incontournable ou si au contraire on se
perd dans les quartiers qui ne sont même
pas mentionné dans le guide du routard
on disait que c'est une approche
quantitative parce qu'on dirait bien que
cette phrase permet de procéder à des
comparaisons un esprit parcours des
étendues plus ou moins vastes eagle
connaît plus de choses que monsieur
dupont la position de hegel et donc
surplombante elle permet de juger et
qu'elle se trouve là et constate que
l'esprit d'un monsieur dupont se
satisfait de moins de 10% de ce que lui
à explorer il s'autorise ainsi à
considérer la perte d'un monsieur dupont
c'est à dire tout ce qu'ils auraient pu
explorer mais qui ne connaîtra jamais à
cause de cette satisfaction une autre
traduction de la phrase c'est à la
facilité avec laquelle l'esprit se
satisfait on peut mesurer l'étendue de
cette perte la notion de faciliter
souligne une dimension de l'aspect
quantitatif
ça fait écho à la question de la
puissance de la performance
un peu comme avec un jeu vidéo celui qui
joue en difficile peut avoir le
sentiment d'accéder à une expérience
plus riche que celle qui proposait en
facile peut-être plus stressante donc
plus immersive
plus réaliste donc plus engageante
émotionnellement quand son pote lui dis
moi je préfère jouer en facile il répond
tu sais pas ce que tu loupes
sous-entendu si tu étais un peu plus
exigeants si tu ne satisfaisait pas du
premier truc venu tu te donnerait
l'occasion de vivre des expériences plus
intéressante
je prends cet exemple pour montrer ce
que la phrase de hegel peut avoir
d'intuitif on a tous expérimenté ça un
jour quand on a commencé à s'intéresser
à quelque chose
ils ont par exemple la poésie on
commence par lire les poètes les plus
connus rimbaud baudelaire mallarmé et
puis parce que ça vous rend curieux on
découvre d'autres choses du siècle
suivant
rené char henri michaux antonin artaud
puis il des choses encore plus récentes
jacques dupin andré du bouchet la revue
l'éphémère puis les choses encore moins
connus guillard cédric demangeot la rue
de conséquences et alors qu'on creuse on
se retourne sur le début de cette
exploration et on se dit à côté de quoi
serait il passé si je m'étais arrêté à
baudelaire et rimbaud
il ne s'agit pas de dire que baudelaire
et rimbaud sont limitées sans doute
peut-on passer une vie entière sur
chacune de ses oeuvres
mais de fait on a découvert des horizons
très varié qui nous seraient restés
inconnus
ça me fait penser à l'effet dany kruger
en gros plus on en sait sur un sujet
moins on se sent compétents et moins on
en sait plus on a confiance dans ses
capacités
ça s'explique très facilement imaginer
un domaine de connaissances on le
représente par un arbre au début on est
sur le tronc et on porte que le tronc
c'est tout ce qu'il ya à savoir
du coup on se dit qu'on sait grosso modo
le principal mais assez rapidement alors
qu'on se renseigne une information nous
indiquent qu'il ya plusieurs
embranchements on peut étudier ce
domaine selon différents angles
on suit une des quatre branches et on a
maintenant à l'esprit que l'on explore
que 25 % du domaine si on en reste là ça
continuerait de vous donner confiance
connaître grosso modo le quart de
quelque chose c'est suffisant pour
pouvoir en parler mais on ne s'arrête
pas là et très vite il ya un autre
embranchements puis un autre et encore
un autre
et comme on pige que c'était paraît de
l'autre côté on comprend vite que notre
connaissance est infime
plus on découvre deux choses plus la
proportion de ceux qu'on connaît
relativement à ce domaine nous paraît un
film au contraire - parcours le champ de
connaissances puis nous sommes le petit
est maîtrisable
ce qui est un peu chiant malgré tout
lecture quantitative c'est qu'elle est
trop linéaire en fait à supposer une
progression toute simple et ça laisse
entendre que qui peut plus peut le moins
donc celui qui a beaucoup bossé un sujet
serait exactement ce que comprend celui
qui débute ça donne une raison à la
condescendance of no bismes et ça
suppose un drôle de rapport à la culture
et à la connaissance comme si chaque
approfondissement englober l'expérience
précédente
la contenait et l'énergie c'est ça
paraît peut-être intuitif mais c'est un
peu limité c'est une sur simplification
ça empêche d'imaginer qu'il ya des modes
de compréhension des façons d'approcher
la réalité beaucoup plus varié que cette
simple addition d'expérience ou de
connaissances un exemple pour illustrer
sa c'est la manière dont ce qui nous a
trait à la cécité dans une célèbre
lettre qu'il adresse à bensberg il
interroge vide et de privations avec le
cas d'une personne aveugle
nous disons par exemple qu'un aveugle et
privés de la vue parce que nous
imaginions facilement clairvoyant soit
par comparaison avec d'autres hommes
clairvoyants soi que nous comparions
l'état présent de cet homme avec son
état passer du temps qu'il voyait quand
donc nous considérons cet homme de la
sorte
comparant sa nature avec celles d'autres
individus ou avec sa nature intérieure
nous affirmant que la vision appartient
à sa nature et pour cette raison nous
disons qu'il en est privé mais si l'on
n'a égard aux décrets de dieu et à la
nature de ce décret on ne peut plus dire
que cet aveugle et privés de la vue
qu'on ne peut le dire d'une pierre car à
ce moment là il serait aussi
contradictoires que la vision lui
appartint qui le serait qu'elle
appartient à la pierre puisque rien
appartient à cet homme et ne peut être
dit 'tiens que ce que l'entendement et
la volonté de dieu lui a accordé
rappelez-vous pour les gens qui ont peur
du mot dieu que chez spinoza c'est
différent et pour les très vite que
c'est synonyme de nature la cécité de la
règle est pour nous un mal un manque
parce que nous pensons que la vision
appartient à sa nature à savoir qu'un
être humain c'est censé être capable de
voir que c'est une puissance qu'un être
humain peut légitimement s'attendre à
avoir et que donc par conséquent la
vague en est privé il manque la vision
jeudi censé pour dire ce qui est supposé
ce à quoi on s'attend ce qu'on prend
pour acquis
on prétend connaître la nature d'un être
humain et donc on pense savoir ce qui
correspond à ce qu'un être humain est
censé être est ce qui est anormal pour
un être humain ce qui n'appartient pas à
sa nature et pour quoi s'autoriser à
penser cela
précisément parce que nous comparons les
choses entre elles ont comparé la dot à
d'autres hommes
donc on se fait rapidement une idée de
l'homme souvent assez étroites
d'ailleurs et tout ce qui s'en éloignent
est observée comme ce qui n'est pas
normal de famille de réaction dominé
vis-à-vis de ce qui sort de la norme la
peur le dégoût le rejet d'une part
l'admiration à l'envi le respect de
l'autre et parfois un petit mélange des
deux un peu malsain la phase de hegel on
a l'impression qu'elle renvoie bien à
notre monde à notre tendance spontanée à
penser qu'il y a tout simplement une
jauge de connaissance et qu'on se situe
plus ou moins au dessus en fonction de
la somme de ce conseil ou alors de la
puissance de son esprit critique chez
charles affichage intellectuelle bac + 2
les gens forte ça m'intéresse d'autant
plus de soulever tout ça parce qu'il est
vrai qu un monde individualiste nouri ce
type de dispositions mentales et que ça
excès de la seule question de la
connaissance
on est constamment invité à comparer
notre situation avec celle des autres
on essaie de savoir où on se situe alors
on se demande consciemment ou non est ce
que je suis plutôt à plaindre ou plutôt
à envier et quand on se demande est-ce
que je suis bon on se demande en fait
est-ce que je suis plutôt meilleurs que
la moyenne des gens en général on vise
toujours le niveau supérieur
parce qu'on s'habitue à son quotidien on
prend pour acquis sa situation et
ensuite on se fixe un nouvel objectif
qui devrait nous rendre heureux comme la
dernière fois qu'on a atteint un
objectif
alors on fait des efforts pour y arriver
et on est récompensé il nous a dit aussi
quelque chose là dessus je dis prie ou
ce n'est pas tant notre niveau de
bonheur qui importe que la différence
avec le niveau précédent ou pour le dire
autrement on donne plus d'importance au
passage d'un degré inférieur à un degré
supérieur de perfection co degré
lui-même exemple quelqu'un qui gagne
1500 euros par mois et apprend qu'il
passe à 1600 sera beaucoup plus heureux
que quelqu'un qui gagne 3500 et qui
apprend que son salaire tombe à 3300 on
ne s'étonne pas chaque matin d'avoir un
toit au-dessus de la tête
et de quoi manger dans le frigo ça nous
semble normal donc pour revenir à
l'exemple de la veille chez spinoza
il faut comprendre que dès qu'une chose
ne semble normal c'est-à-dire dès qu'une
chose est une norme pour nous alors le
verbe sens et intervient inconsciemment
on pense je suis censé avoir deux yeux
elle où je suis censé avoir un toit
au-dessus de la tête et de quoi manger
plutôt que de s'émerveiller tous les
jours de la chance au sens propre
on a d'être en vie on prend tout un tas
de trucs pour un qui la vision pour ce
qu'ils voient louis pour se dit entendre
etc
attention on discours se situe ici sur
un plan davantage métaphysique ou
existentielle kg éthique et politique
je ne suis pas en train de dire que les
gens qui n'est dans la misère devrait
déjà s'estimer heureux d'être en vie
évidemment si des gens arrivent à être
heureux parce qu ils s'émerveillent du
seul fait d'être en vie
c'est super cool et on est tous
admiratifs mais ça ne change rien en
fait que partant du principe qu'une
telle disposition mentale est quasi
impossible à avoir pour la plupart
d'entre nous on ne saurait remettre en
cause la responsabilité de la société à
redistribuer les richesses pour éviter
les inégalités arbitraire
c'est le souci avec le même faire soit
problème bien sûr on peut en rigoler
quand on parle de fringues pas à la mode
ou de réservation au restaurant annulées
ne va pas se mettre à niveler par le bas
non plus donc ne nous trompons pas de
raisonnement c'est pas parce que des
gens vivent avec moins de 1 1 euro par
jour que c'est ok pour le gouvernement
français et de baisser les apl
bref revenons à ce principe
psychologique donc il ya cette phrase de
hegel c'est une dynamique de conquête
d'appropriation ça fonctionne aussi bien
pour l'accumulation de biens matériels
la recherche du pouvoir la colonisation
des pays où la quête de connaissances
donc puisqu'on était partie de la presse
rappelle comme on l'évoqué brièvement
dans la deuxième vidéo sur le
confinement baudrillard met en lumière
dans ses deux premiers ouvrages que la
valeur d'usagé des objets est fortement
concurrencée par la valeur symbolique
on achète de moins en moins les choses
en tant qu'outil est de plus en plus en
tant que signe distinctif
c'est à dire des codes qui nous font
appartenir à un groupe social plutôt
qu'un autre
la soif d'accumulation et de signes
distinctifs touche aussi notre désir
d'expérience on veut les meilleures
vacances les plus beaux voyages les
meilleures soirées et aussi des
meilleurs raisonnement les plus belles
pensées
cette fuite en avant consumériste
concerne aussi la connaissance et ça ne
manque pas d'enjeux symbolique ce qu'ils
découvrent l'esprit critique où les étés
tic peuvent hors tendance à s'en
enorgueillir avoir la pression qu on
décode les erreurs les plus fréquentes
dans les raisonnements d'autrui ça donne
aussi une position de surplomb ça ferait
croire qu'on en sait plus et que nous
avaient mieux à comprendre la réalité
quand on se lance dans une ascension
culturel ou intellectuelle on sent qu'on
a besoin d'accumuler les connaissances
les concepts les idées parfois même
jusqu'à l' angoisse
à cet égard j'ai bien rappeler ce que
dit deleuze dans l'abécédaire a versé
ces pots culture enfin quand je dis que
je suis dit que le tibet dia
d'intellectuels je veux dire une chose
très facile c'est que je n'ai aucun
savoir de réserve
aucun savoir au barrage avait pas de
problèmes à maman va pas chercher ce que
j'ai à publier rien rien de cgg autour
de réserve
j'ai rien j'ai aucune provision n'a
aucun savoir provisionnelle et tout ce
que j'apprends je la prends pour tel
trash et là tu as fait je vous lis si
bien que 6 10 ans après je suis français
alors ça bloque beaucoup de joie syfy
forcé de me remettre dans quelque chose
de voisins ou dans le bas bugey
je dois commencer à dire il y a un sens
de la légèreté dans ce qu'il dit
j'apprends quelque chose pour une action
fut et mentale et ensuite j'oublie je me
débarrasse de ce savoir en comprend le
ses provisions culturel si on reprend la
carte et griene deleuze lui il ne
conquiert pas du terrain ils se
déplacent furtivement jusqu'au point
qu'il a identifiés comme stratégique ce
qui l'intéresse c'est un autre rapport
au territoire mentale eagle et dans
l'occupation il veut recouvrir le
territoire deleuze lui vis des positions
des points de vue peut-être parce qu'ils
permettent une certaine puissance
on passe d'une logique accumulative et
totalisant à une jcct sélective et
fonctionnels tels savoir pour quelle
utilité
spontanément il semblerait que les gens
sont plutôt hégélien et une raison pour
laquelle la position hégélienne et
séduisant c'est que la logique
accumulative implique une croyance à mon
avis erronée on a déjà évoqué tout à
l'heure à savoir l'idée selon laquelle
qui peut le plus peut le moins
comme si en apprenant plein de choses je
conserver un accès à l'état d'esprit que
j'avais avant d'apprendre ces choses
comme s'ils accumulent et de la
connaissance ne permettaient de cumuler
des points de vue celui qui sait rien
celui qui s'est un peu celui qui s'est
beaucoup et c'est une façon de
représenter cette croyance ça veut dire
qu'on a tendance à voir l'esprit comme
un ordinateur genre à prendre un truc
c'est ajouté
chier apprendre une technique maîtrisée
à savoir faire s'est ajouté un logiciel
etc et on croit qu'on a toujours accès à
l'architecturé fondamental dans notre
esprit ce lieu neutre et non biaisée où
on peut taper des lignes de commande si
on veut repartir de zéro pour
reprogrammer notre cerveau on se dit
travailler ses raisonnements apprendre
des choses ce sont de simples agents ça
ne modifie pas le système d'exploitation
c'est une erreur apprendre quelque chose
c'est changer son esprit même de manière
imperceptible s'est donc déplacé son
point de vue il faut au contraire
imaginer qu'à chaque ligne de commande
comptable on transforme un système
d'exploitation ont fait bouger les
architectures de notre esprit un autre
gros gros problème avec cette conception
de l'esprit comme système d'exploitation
c'est qu'elle tend à faire croire
qu'avoir une bonne capacité de calcul
que savoir traiter correctement les
informations sans être trop biaisé ça
permet de penser n'importe quelle
situation de réfléchir à n'importe
quelle question
je passe sur le fait que ça me paraît
impossible de penser sans être sujets au
moindre biais ce n'est même pas le
problème le problème c'est de croire que
cet esprit idéal qui traiterait
parfaitement les informations peut tout
pensé et c'est à mon avis un point
central de ce qu'on appelle les seven
swans du youtuber et éthicien bien
intentionnés à sokal et bricmont on
retrouve cette idée selon laquelle on
pourrait juger les travaux de sciences
humaines et sociales sans avoir passé
des années à les fréquenter simplement
parce qu'on se réjouit d'une bonne
capacité de réflexion
d'un côté on accepte l'idée qu'il soit
difficile de comprendre un dénoncé
mathématiques et que cela demande des
années de travail pour devenir physicien
mais de l'autre on feint d'ignorer qu'il
faut le même type d'engagement et la
même quantité de temps passé pour
comprendre une théorie anthropologique
par exemple pour maîtriser les concepts
qui permettent de penser la société
on se dit j'ai une capacité de
raisonnement suffisante pour réfléchir
aux problèmes du monde
notez d'ailleurs qu'on te dis pas ça par
pure confiance dans l'esprit humain
parce qu'on croit que tout le monde peut
réfléchir aux problèmes du monde
c'est plutôt parce qu on se pense
capable soi-même en vertu de certaines
capacités intellectuelles
ce qui fait qu'elle contredit pas il
faudrait que je lis de la philosophie
est que je prenne du temps à essayer de
méditer ces différentes manières de
penser il y à une situation qui illustre
pourquoi se sont majoritairement ceux
qui ont une formation en sciences dures
qui font cette erreur car oui vous avez
remarqué
on entend rarement un sociologue se
prononcer sur une théorie physique
quand je donne des cours à la fac je me
disais que j'étais content de pas être
prof de maths pour ne pas vivre langlois
de tomber sur will hunting un étudiant
surdoué qui te met la fille devant toute
la classe
mais monsieur on peut résoudre ce
problème bien plus facilement regarder
parce qu'en fait ça n'existe pas les
surdoses en philo et jamais un étudiant
ou une étudiante de 18 ans capable de
révéler une subtilité conceptuel un prof
une prof plus expérimentés pourquoi pas
parce que ça prend du temps
les sciences humaines et sociales un
temps incompressible
c'est le temps qu'il faut pour tisser
une relation avec les concepts avec les
mots avec des formes langage r auquel on
n'est pas habitué avec des manières de
réfléchir qui déborde la forme logique
parce que ça prend un temps très long
d'apprivoiser un point de vue différent
sur le monde parce qu'il n'ya pas de
niveau facile en philosophie sa demande
toujours une contention vantal de
comprendre ce qu une pensée implique et
cette contorsion requiert de la
souplesse
il faut assouplir son esprit au moins à
ce niveau là les chercheurs en sciences
humaines et sociales font une expérience
directe de ce que ça implique de changer
son point de vue en fils de filles
maîtriser un concept implique de pouvoir
adopter son point de vue c'est à dire de
pouvoir sentir ce que cela implique de
penser et vivre à travers lui ce
déplacement de point de vue prend du
temps et surtout il est irréversible
on peut plus faire comme avant on peut
pas oublier ce qu'on a ressenti en
pensant avec ce concept on peut pas
oublier l'image du monde que ce concept
nous a présenté quand on l'a adopté je
ne sais pas si ceux qui ont une
formation en sciences dures se rendent
bien compte de ça que même s'ils sont
très très intelligent il leur faudrait
quand même passé quatre ou cinq ans avec
un philosophe pour commencer à le
comprendre il faut dire que ces
disciplines ne présente pas la même
genre de difficulté celle des sciences
dures sont plus évidentes plus visible
il faut déjà réussir à déchiffrer ce qui
est écrit l'ansa paraît objectivement
plus compliqué les difficultés associées
aux sciences humaines et sociales ne
s'impose pas au premier coup d'oeil
puisque elle se révèle avec le temps et
qu'elle implique un travail
d'incarnation il faut que se transforme
le corps de l'intérieur oui parce que
pour penser il faut encore et on ne
saurait sous-estimer le rôle que le
corps joue dans l'élaboration de nos
pensées c'est pour ça que non qui peut
le plus ne peut pas loin apprendre ça
transforme en fait il faudrait dire
qui peut le plus perd complètement de vu
ce que c'était de ne pas pouvoir pour
reprendre la dimension matérielle parce
qu'elle est facile à imaginer devenir
riche c'est perdre de vue tout un tas
d'expériences associé au fait des
pauvres
quand on possède beaucoup d'argent on
peut vite avoir peur de perdre ce souci
la crainte de voir sa fortune
disparaître c'est évidemment associe qui
n'existe pas quand on est pauvre et le
confrère est vrai aussi quelqu'un de
riche n'est pas capable de ressentir la
crainte de ne pas pouvoir payer son
loyer
et pour ce qui est de l'intellect c'est
pareil développées telles et telles
capacités mentales ou acquérir telle et
telle connaissance permet cette
expérience et en empêche d'autres
donc non encore une fois qui peut plus
ne peut pas le mans mais comme on est
pris dans cette créance fallacieuses on
se dit que multiplier des expériences et
forcément mieux bon mais alors comment
aborder les choses différemment
il est où l'adversaire de la gueule nous
voilà lao tseu contemporain de confucius
donc au vième siècle avant jésus-christ
il est considéré à posteriori comme le
fondateur du taoïsme et c'est une
véritable machine à citation pour
coucher de soleil puisqu'il aurait dit
qu'ils se contentent de peu et riche
on retrouve bien là le genre de clichés
propres est ce qu'on appelle
maladroitement la sagesse orientale et
comme souvent avec ce genre de piché bas
ce n'est un pichet que parce qu'à
première vue c'est intellectuellement
facile à comprendre mais à mettre en
pratique il faut se rendre à l'évidence
que presque personne n'y arrivent jamais
d'ailleurs
j'avoue que je suis toujours un peu plus
impressionné par celui qui réussit par
la réflexion a changé sa sensibilité a
transformé son quotidien
rien qu'un peu que par celui qui est un
gâteau ce du concept mais continuer
d'entretenir ses névroses
c'est en cela que j'ai pour ainsi dire
que sa phrase répond à celle de hegel
cdh estime manteaux très différents qui
se contente de peu et riche
oui on se dit que ça demande pas des
kilomètres d'exégèse et que c'est super
difficile à appliquer par exemple un
soir chez moi alors que je me régalais
de mon dîner je me félicitais de sa
simplicité du riz est une chose pour
l'accompagner avec des oignons et des
haricots noirs rien de grandiose et
pourtant c'était divin
je me suis demandé si j'étais en train
de me rapprocher de cet idéal taoïste
mais très vite je me suis rendu compte
que pas du tout tout ce que j'ai fait
c'était appliqué une autre phrase un peu
moins ambitieuse qui se contentent de
choses
peuchère peut se faire souvent plaisir à
peu de frais parce que les oignons j'ai
fait revenir dans l'huile avec de l'ail
puis déglacer au vinaigre docile puis-je
ajouter du thym de l'origan cayenne
chili dollar et ça je ne vous raconte
pas ça pour exhiber mais vague
compétences culinaires mais pour
expliquer la différence entre peu et peu
chères en plat n'avait peut-être côté
qu'un euro ou à peine plus il n'empêche
qu'il était pour être saveur
je ne me suis pas contenté de peu
puisque mon expérience gustative était
pleine à craquer se contenter de peu ce
serait propre
autant de plaisir avec un bol de riz
blanc points il s'agit donc plutôt de ne
même pas cherché à vivre des expériences
riches mais est ce que ça veut dire que
l'expérience est pauvre pas sûr et c'est
pour ça qu'en fait cette phrase elle est
peut-être bien plus compliqué qu'il n'y
paraît si on se contente de peu cela
semble aussi dire qu énormément de
choses sont susceptibles de provoquer
notre contentement et si on pousse cette
logique jusqu'au bout c'est que chaque
situation même celle qui paraît la plus
insignifiante est perçu comme infiniment
profonde c'est un autre rapport à
l'échelle d'intensité des expériences ça
invite à distinguer les rapport à
l'expérience et peut-être que la clé se
trouve dans le mot qu'emploie eagle
satisfaction d'un côté on aurait un
rapport à l'expérience dominé par la
recherche d'un état de plaisir de
l'autre une paix profonde chez celui qui
cessent de désirer d'un côté une
attitude qui nourrit l'excitation est
donc le désir de conquête que ce soit
ascension sociale de richesse ou la soif
de connaissance de l'autre une attitude
calme et apaisé alors que père lahoud ce
que perton à ne pas vouloir conquérir
que perton si on ne connaît pas le désir
de posséder
rappelons qu'on a peut perdre que ce
qu'on a si on a le sentiment de ne rien
posséder on perd la crainte de perdre
quoi que ce soit de la même manière on
ne peut passer à côté d'une chose que si
connaissant son existence on
souhaiterait la connaître
d'où le danger de la comparaison twitter
youtube font de bons exemples
si je considère que j'ai acquis des
followers ou des abonnés je peux crainte
de les voir partir
et si je vais regarder le nombre de
followers du voisin je peux être tenté
de juger qu'avec mes 230 followers je
passe à côté d'une expérience
extraordinaire mais attention pour ce
qui est de l'ambition sociale
effectivement on voit bien l'intérêt de
voir les choses ainsi mais pour ce qui
est de l'ambition intellectuelle ne
risque-t-on pas de tomber dans l'écueil
classique de l'ain
si l'heureux de la douce ignorance
laporte existentielle de la phrase de
lao-tseu est en réalité beaucoup trop
profonde pour que je puisse aborder
sérieusement ici considérons que dans ce
combat
le maître taoïste à un peu retenu ses
coups parce que sinon la puissance du
coup n'est pas conforme aux règles du m1
pourquoi est ce qu'ils savent
précisément parce que ce sont deux modes
de pensée qui ne fonctionne pas selon
les mêmes règles
la logique d'un côté avec la nécessité
de surmonter la contradiction afin de
produire un discours qui sache prendre
raison de la réalité de l'autre une
approche paradoxale qui cherchent au
contraire à maintenir la contradiction
pour profiter de l'attention qui en
émerge afin d'en faire une puissance de
transformation de l'expérience parce que
tenter d'embrasser une contradiction
discursive sans la résoudre cela fait
travailler la souplesse de notre
conscience et permet de développer de
nouvelles capacités affective un peu
comme si ce qui nous a d'ailleurs
puisqu'il s'agit également d'éprouver
une situation paradoxale dans la mesure
où on se libère précisément quand on
reconnaît qu'on est déterminé mais donc
qu'en est-il de l'application de cette
attitude dans la vie sociale on dit
souvent à raison me semble-t-il que les
intentions importe peu en politique que
ça n'a aucun sens de déclarer qu on est
féministe en son for intérieur
si c'est pour balancer des truites aux
effets potentiellement misogyne en fait
c'est pas tellement que l'intention
n'importe pas dans l'absolu c'est
surtout du moins quand on est con sic en
soliste que ne pèse pas lourd quand elle
est contredite par les effets réels des
actions ça me rappelle les gens qui te
font du mal et 10 ensuite j'ai pas fait
exprès pour s'excuser
on a envie de répondre j'aurais voulu
que je fasse exprès de faire attention à
ne pas faire même on se fout de la
tension on qu'il s'agit d' excuses et
des pratiques toxiques mais on pourrait
défendre l'idée que si on avait vraiment
la bonne attention alors justement on
évite rédaction aux effets néfastes
avoir l'intention consciente de faire
attention aux autres ça prévient
beaucoup de maladresses et je crois
qu'en ce sens la phrase de lao-tseu
indique le niveau supplémentaire
d'exigence du point de vue de la vie
intérieure aussi bien pour ce qui est
des désirs matériels que de l'ambition
intellectuelle commençons par la
question matérielle avec les armes
classiques de la consommation pour que
ce soit convaincant essayez d'imaginer
le truc que vous aimez le plus consommé
pour certains c'est la technologie sont
fans des smartphones pour d'autres et
des baskets les vêtements les objets de
découpe importer les implications
politiques sociales existent
si elles ne sont pas identiques selon
les objets que l'on consomme mais ici on
s'attache aux principes communs à tous
ces actes de consommation
l'achat d'un symbole d'un confort ou
d'une expérience comme synonyme de
plaisirs subir totalement son désir
consumériste c'est voir dans l'acte de
consommation le principal levier d'une
quête de plaisir ensuite on peut
distinguer différents degré
d'émancipation vis-à-vis de ce désir
c'est une chose de contrer consciemment
son désir d'acheter un nouveau
smartphone parce qu'on ne veut pas faire
le jeu de la société de consommation
c'en est une autre d'avoir carrément
éteint ce désir définitivement qu'ils ne
représentent aucune menace en quelque
sorte qu'ils ne soient pas susceptibles
de surgir sans qu'on s'en rende compte
il nous fasse craquer un jour pour tel
ou tel produit inutile c'en est encore
une autre d'avoir débranché sa capacité
à profiter des plaisirs associés à la
consommation
que ce soit un nouveau téléphone mais
aussi des bons restaurants dépôt
d'objets le confort dans son ensemble et
ce même si tout ça ne vous est offert
bien sûr à sont les gens qui pensent
sincèrement toutes choses égales par
ailleurs
je préfère un studio un deux pièces où
je préfère les douches froides où je
préfère dormir à même le sol
ça existe mais c'est pas très fréquent
et c'est important parce que affecté
idée donc sentiments et idéologies se
nourrissent mutuellement les affects
d'un des idées les sentiments angad
autre conception du monde de l'autre
côté
l'image que nous nous faisons de la
réalité de la société d'autrui établi un
système de valeurs qui à son tour nous
pousse à rechercher des sentiments
plutôt que tel autre
nous nous étions dans une société qui
n'est évidemment pas neutre
idéologiquement
ainsi nous héritons d'un système de
valeurs qui définit notre relation aux
affects et bien entendu notre rapport au
sentiment va définir nos prises de
décision donc par extension les actions
et les conséquences que celles ci auront
sur le monde ce qui va venir confirmer
ou infirmer la valeur que nous
attribuons aux sentiments nous
questionner que notre rapport aux idées
c'est en ce sens faire l'amour du
travail
si on ne se penche pas sérieusement sur
notre rapport au plaisir on laisse
rentrer l'idéologie dominante par la
porte de derrière
si pour reprendre la définition de
michel foucault faire preuve d'esprit
critique c'est l'art de mettre pas
tellement gouverner alors je crois qu'il
faut aussi prendre en compte les
dispositions affectif qui nous
gouvernent
ce qui ne veut pas dire évidemment
nourrir le rêve naïfs d'une vie sans
affect plus simplement
il faut garder à l'esprit le rôle que
notre relation au plaisir joue dans nos
choix de vie
la phrase de la au dessus à cette porte
et qui se contente de peu et riche
n'implique pas une vie vide et de
maurice est là pour vous le rappeler et
plus il est facile d'être contenter voie
ont subi nos désirs tyrannique et moi
nous laissons la course à la sa
situation personnelle définir notre vie
il ne s'agit pas je le répète de
responsabiliser l'individu où le
consommateur et il est toujours facile
de dire à ceux qui n'ont rien
contentez-vous de peu ce n'est pas le
message en jeu ici le temps qu'ils
excèdent la seule question matérielle se
contenter de peu c'est aussi vrai pour
la question symbolique par exemple se
contenter de peu de flower ou de peu
d'abonnés de manière générale mais pas
désiré de reconnaissance quant à sa
valeur personnelle et limité son
ambition on pourrait être tenté de
répondre mais il faut bien penser la
société si on ne cherche pas à la
comprendre
on pourra pas régler ces problèmes et en
effet je crois que ce contentement
n'implique pas du tout un désintérêt
pour les questions sociales
il s'agit de limiter son ambition
personnelle pas son désir d'aider les
autres parce qu'on ne saurait concevoir
le désir altruistes comme quelque chose
qui serait satisfait par un contentement
personnel peut être qu'on peut revenir à
deux justement pour éclairer lao tseu
travailler et apprendre mais pour
pouvoir faire quelque chose donc par
exemple à prendre pour mieux comprendre
comment f1 ou une bonne potes un bon
père ou une bonne mère à prendre pour
mieux défendre le féminisme à prendre
pour mieux lutter contre un système
inégalitaire à prendre pour les autres
en fait donc apprendre à écouter et pas
à prendre pour se sentir plus
intelligent plus fort pour devenir un
dominant culturel et donner des leçons
de rationalité aux autres pas pour être
fière de savoir plein de choses pas pour
prouver qu'on a raison donc pas pour soi
donc pas à prendre à imposer son point
de vue parce que vous savez ce qu'ils
écoulaient cas au dessus c'est que celui
qui se contente de peu et déjà un riche
alors tout le temps qu'ils auraient
passée à courir après le succès ou la
connaissance
il peut les passer à se préoccuper des
autres
salut à bientôt